Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Avrete sentito parlare di immigrazione
e di migranti, ultimamente.
Giusto un po’, vagamente.
Avrete sentito di storie
di stranieri che invadono
il nostro territorio e le nostre città;
di storie di migranti
su imbarcazioni di fortuna
che attraversano il Mediterraneo
e che giungono fino alle nostre coste.
Alcuni di loro perdono
anche la vita, nel tentativo.
Avrete sentito anche
delle storie positive,
di rifugiati che decidono di donare
i fondi a loro destinati
ai terremotati italiani, per esempio,
o di migranti che intraprendono
attività commerciali che funzionano.
La storia della migrazione
è la storia dell'uomo.
Ed è una storia
che parte da molto lontano:
anche nella mia famiglia, ad esempio.
Mio nonno è emigrato dal Salento al Belgio
all’inizio degli anni '50,
in corrispondenza
del disastro di Marcinelle
dove persero la vita, tra gli altri,
136 minatori italiani.
I miei genitori si sono spostati
da sud verso nord Italia;
mio zio ha lavorato
moltissimi anni in Svizzera;
e io stesso ho passato
tre anni della mia vita
a Londra, in Inghilterra,
a fare un dottorato di ricerca,
anche se nell'immaginario collettivo
non ero un migrante:
ero un italiano all'estero, o un expat,
secondo un vocabolo
che si sta affermando sempre di più.
Come nella mia famiglia,
sono convinto che anche
in molte delle vostre famiglie
ci siano storie simili di emigrazione.
E c'è un filo conduttore di queste storie,
un unico filo che è l'emozione:
l'emozione in chi la vive,
che vi racconterà
che è una delle esperienze più intense
che abbia mai passato nella vita;
e l'emozione in chi la osserva
da una certa distanza.
L'informazione, la politica,
e sempre di più i social
si nutrono di queste sensazioni istintive
e finiscono anche con l’avere
un impatto sulla nostra percezione,
specialmente su tematiche
come quelle della migrazione.
Non è un caso che.
secondo l'ultimo Eurobarometro,
che è il servizio
della Commissione Europea
che guarda alle tendenze
dell'opinione pubblica,
l'immigrazione è la principale causa
di preoccupazione dei cittadini europei,
seguita dal terrorismo.
Per contro, solo il 37% degli intervistati
si ritiene informato sulla migrazione.
Su 19 paesi su 28
la percezione del rapporto
fra emigrati extraeuropei e popolazione
è di più del doppio
di quello che non sia in realtà.
E in Italia?
Chiedo a voi:
secondo voi, qual è la percentuale
di immigrati extraeuropei in Italia?
Chi pensa "Tra lo zero
e il dieci percento", alzi la mano.
La metà.
Tra il 10 e il 20%?
Un po' meno.
Tra il 20 e il 30%?
Qualcuno.
Oltre il 30?
Nessuno, meno male.
La percezione in Italia media è del 24,6%,
quando in realtà i dati ci dicono
che solo sette sono immigrati
su 100 abitanti in Italia.
Questi sono i dati ufficiali,
in questo sette percento,
ed io vi parlerò di dati oggi.
Sono un data scientist
e quello che amo dei dati
è che difficilmente mentono,
ma possono essere utilizzati
per sfatare dei miti, degli stereotipi.
Ad esempio,
in Africa, il numero maggiore di migranti
si muove all'interno del continente
e solo una parte di loro
finiscono verso altri continenti,
quindi non c'è un esodo
di massa verso l'Europa.
Oppure, il flusso di messicani
verso gli Stati Uniti
è minore di quello che dagli Stati Uniti
va verso il Messico:
molti sono migranti di ritorno
che si ricongiungono ai loro familiari,
e questo dato riguarda
sia irregolari che regolari.
Sicuramente un dato
che è in controtendenza
rispetto alla percezione, alla narrazione
che ci è stata trasmessa
negli ultimi tempi.
Al Joint Research Centre
della Commissione Europea
ospitiamo un centro di conoscenza
sulla migrazione e la demografia.
E uno dei compiti principali
di questo centro
è di mettere ordine nei dati,
capire dove sono disponibili,
capire quali sono le limitazioni
e cercare di migliorare la situazione.
Un altro dato interessante
è la percentuale di migranti
a livello globale.
Questo grafico ci dice
che negli ultimi 20 - 30 anni
il rapporto non è variato molto.
La popolazione da un lato
cresce a livello globale,
e il numero di migranti
crescono a livello globale,
ma il loro rapporto
non varia sensibilmente.
Quello che cambia
sono i flussi e le direzioni.
L'Europa è sempre stata,
fino a qualche decennio fa,
un punto di partenza;
adesso è prevalentemente
un punto di arrivo,
anche se dal sud Europa
si continua a partire molto.
I dati ci aiutano, anche,
a capire una relazione
che è molto poco conosciuta
ed è sicuramente poco intuitiva,
ed è fra la crescita,
fra lo sviluppo economico di un paese
ed i flussi di emigrazione.
Siamo portati a pensare
che è dai paesi più poveri
che i cittadini emigrino di più;
questo non è vero, anzi è vero l'opposto,
perché non hanno né gli strumenti
né l’aspirazione per farlo.
È solo quando il loro
sviluppo economico cresce,
che i flussi crescono,
fino a raggiungere
il picco di questa curva
che è detta la “gobba della migrazione”,
oltre la quale
le opportunità che si troverebbero
fuori dal paese di origine
equivalgono più o meno
a quelle del paese di destinazione,
quindi i flussi cominciano a scendere.
Con questo non voglio dire
che dobbiamo smettere
di aiutare i paesi più poveri,
perché abbiamo un obbligo morale di farlo;
ma non dobbiamo aspettarci
che i flussi diminuiscano,
al crescere dello sviluppo economico.
Un altro dato importante ci dice
che l'emigrazione in sé è un aiuto
allo sviluppo dei paesi di origine;
i soldi che mandano i migranti
alle loro famiglie di origine, le rimesse,
costituiscono uno strumento finanziario
che eccede di gran lunga gli aiuti diretti
dei paesi più ricchi
verso quelli più poveri.
Tutti questi dati che servono
a ricavare questi bellissimi grafici
e queste informazioni, questa conoscenza,
sono dati raccolti in decine di anni
da decine di paesi,
e messi insieme
da organizzazioni internazionali
come la Banca Mondiale,
le Nazioni Unite, Eurostat in Europa.
Ma questi dati, le statistiche ufficiali,
non ci dicono quello
che sta accadendo nell'immediato.
E non ci dicono neanche
alcune caratteristiche
socio-economiche e demografiche
che sono fondamentali
per delle politiche adeguate
sulla migrazione.
In questo abbiamo una buona notizia.
Abbiamo un gruppo di lavoro
internazionale, col quale lavoriamo,
e abbiamo analizzato
quelle che sono le sorgenti alternative
per descrivere l'emigrazione:
i big data.
E una di queste possibili vie
è offerta dai social stessi.
Ci sono delle piattaforme
attraverso le quali si possono fare
inserzioni pubblicitarie,
lo avrete visto nei vostri feed.
Bene, se avete un prodotto
e volete pubblicizzarlo, per esempio,
a: expat; italiani;
in Inghilterra; maschi;
in una fascia di età dai 35 ai 40 anni,
Facebook, Linkedin, e Twitter
vi restituiscono un numero
sulla base del quale poi
vi chiederanno il conto,
ma è un numero di persone
che raggiungereste
se faceste questa
inserzione pubblicitaria.
Se poi cambiate il genere,
e cambiate la fascia di età,
e cambiate l’expat
dalla Francia alla Spagna
o dagli Stati Uniti alla Russia,
sequenzialmente è possibile
costruire un censimento,
in tempo reale e a livello globale.
Ed è quello che abbiamo fatto.
E per dimostrare il valore di questo,
questa è un’analisi
che riguarda i venezuelani in Spagna.
I venezuelani stanno emigrando moltissimo;
molti di loro finiscono
con l’emigrare in Spagna,
per ovvie ragioni culturali.
I dati delle statistiche ufficiali
sono con cadenza annuale,
e arrivano fino al gennaio del 2017.
E poi c'è un vuoto,
che può essere colmato con dati nazionali,
in questo caso del registro
della popolazione spagnola,
che arriva al gennaio del 2018, in giallo.
Con Facebook è possibile
completare questa serie
e capire il trend,
e ricostruirlo fino ad oggi,
in un valore inestimabile
dal punto di vista della conoscenza
di quello che sta succedendo
in questo momento.
Stessa cosa per LinkedIn,
che è il social
delle relazioni professionali:
è possibile fare la stessa cosa.
In questo caso,
abbiamo chiesto a LinkedIn
di dirci dove sono le utenze,
il numero di utenti
che hanno studiato in Siria,
e che probabilmente, quindi, sono Siriani,
e dove si trovano adesso in Europa.
E questa è la mappa che viene fuori.
La distribuzione che vedete è molto simile
e riflette fedelmente la distribuzione
dei richiedenti asilo
che sono recentemente arrivati in Europa.
Quello che non vi dice questa mappa
è che siamo in grado, anche, di capire
qual è la distribuzione di ingegneri,
di infermieri, di dottori, di insegnanti.
Ed è un'informazione fondamentale,
per le politiche a livello comunitario,
ma anche nazionale e locale,
per l'integrazione e la coesione sociale.
Ovviamente questi dati
devono essere trattati con cautela,
ci sono delle questioni di tipo etico,
di privacy, di sicurezza,
del fatto che non abbiamo
controllo, su questi social,
anche dal punto di vista degli account.
Molti di noi probabilmente
nemmeno hanno un account,
alcuni più di uno,
quindi dobbiamo correggere
per tutte queste cose.
E probabilmente non arriveremo mai, però,
a una sostituzione
delle statistiche ufficiali,
perché quelle sono affidabili,
e hanno un processo
che è rodato nel tempo.
Quindi faranno da complemento a questo,
molto probabilmente.
E ci daranno delle indicazioni
che non riusciamo a vedere
nelle statistiche ufficiali di oggi.
Questi dati sono fondamentali;
ma se non diamo loro un contesto,
non vogliono dire molto.
Io un dato lo posso gridare fortissimo,
e farlo diventare enorme,
però, se poi gli metto un contesto,
lo posso smascherare,
lo posso rimettere in riga, diciamo.
Bene, l'informazione
che noi estraiamo dai dati,
la conoscenza,
e una fase altrettanto importante
che è quella della raccolta del dato.
E questi dati abbiamo capito
che sono fondamentali per le politiche.
Questi dati, e questa
conoscenza, ci dimostrano
che la migrazione
non è un fenomeno emergenziale,
ma una parte strutturale
della nostra società.
È ineludibile,
non ci possiamo fare niente.
Probabilmente è destinata
anche ad aumentare, o a rimanere costante.
Difficilmente diminuirà.
Quindi quella cosa
che possiamo fare, l'unica,
è gestirla al meglio,
cercare di sfruttarne il potenziale.
E magari affrontare qualche sfida
che già stiamo vedendo adesso,
e che nel futuro ci coinvolgerà molto,
quale l'invecchiamento demografico,
o la mancanza di manodopera
in determinati settori.
I dati, però,
se li mettiamo a confronto
con la percezione,
sappiamo benissimo
che non hanno nessun effetto.
Anzi, parliamo di età
della post-verità apposta;
c'è un motivo.
Quindi in questo caso, forse,
per la percezione è bene
confrontarci di più
con le storie dei singoli,
le storie di quei migranti,
di quei familiari, amici,
conoscenti che abbiamo.
E voglio lasciarvi con un invito,
invito a chiedere loro
di raccontarvi la loro storia.
Se avranno tempo, e disponibilità,
sarà emozionantissimo.
E vi racconteranno
di difficoltà incredibili,
di emozioni e di sacrificio,
ma anche di soddisfazioni.
Soddisfazione, magari, di avercela fatta,
come nel caso di Juan Carlos
che è arrivato in Italia dal Perù
circa 20 anni fa.
Ed è solo con questa empatia,
con queste emozioni,
che possiamo affrontare
la percezione di quella pancia
che ci fa vedere la realtà, e il mondo,
diversi da quello che sono.
Grazie.
(Applausi)